tell me about that Bhishma Cromartie
he's a designer from maryland's is an
african-american designer he decided to
dress me today
make something couture to address all my
curve the new season the prison riot
let's talk about it for a second if we
want to turn this place right we have to
speak as one United group how was it
filming that because it must have been
weird because it's only three days so
it's okay so there was no miss where I'm
like wait I'm in this still in the same
clothes still in the same emotional
state for three days within a six month
period so it was good exhaustion like
you go home you're like wow I just gave
in my work today eating Cheetos for six
months and that's what I want to know
what did women think like as you went
through the whole arc of having the baby
and everything like how many women
reached out to you and how did that
affect people we're talking about women
in prison that are having babies how you
know these discussions that were swept
under the rug are being brought to light
and we're actually talking about them
that's the first step to cause change
dascha Polanco also told ET at the 2017
Beatty Awards she's unsure if she's
returning for orange is the new black
six season we never have control as in
life when you're in prison you don't
know if you're survived if you'll be
transferred if they'll keep you in there
they set you free so it's very
unexpected we don't know where it's
going we know there's a season six but
we don't know where her destiny is and
that's his life unless like hire a
psychic somebody
the future